let's think about how put options can
give us leverage on a downside or I
should say on a bet that the stock will
go down relative to shorting and this
one's a little bit more complicated
because shorting is a little bit less
intuitive but if you were to short a
stock in order to shore it you might say
hey wait I don't have to put any money
up front because I essentially just
borrow the stock immediately and then I
would sell it for $50 but the reality is
you do have to put some capital upfront
because the short can move against you
and usually you have to put at least 50%
of the value of the short so in our
short scenario you would have to put at
least $25 up front and then you would
borrow the stock sell it for 50 and so
you would essentially have 75 dollars to
play with that you would eventually have
to use to buy back the stock but the
upfront capital is 25 now in our
scenario where the stock went down which
was a good thing if you're shorting you
want the stock that was your bet you
want it to go down in the scenario where
the stock went down to $20 you made a
profit of $30 you were able to buy that
stock for 20 and then give it back to
the original person so you were able to
keep that $50 although net for that 20
so you made $30 so you made $30 on a 25
dollar investment so your your gain you
make a hundred and what is that you make
$25 and then another $5 so that's a
hundred and twenty percent gain so let
me write that down
you made a hundred and twenty percent
gain of course of course in this
scenario you gained when the stock went
down in terms of loss here when the
stock went up the stock went up to $80
we lost $30 by shorting so we had a
hundred and twenty percent loss so once
again a hundred and twenty percent loss
and it's important to realize in a short
situation the best thing that can happen
for you is your stock go to zero in
which case you can kind of you can buy
it back for nothing which means you
could keep your $50 so in the best
possible scenario you have to put $25 up
front you can keep the $50 that you
from borrowing and selling the stock so
you can make a 200% return in the worst
case scenario this is the the best
scenarios this is 200% in the worst case
this would be infinite so you have to be
very careful while you're shorting but
let's think about the put option in the
put option we only have to put five
dollars upfront to actually buy the put
and when the stock went down to 20
dollars when the stock went down to 20
dollars we made 15 so this was a 300%
gain and on the other side of the
equation when the stock went up the
worst we could do is just lose all of
our money so the worst thing we could do
is just lose 100% so once again we were
able to multiply we were able to
multiply our gains relative to shorting
although it's a little bit more mixed on
the downside because the put gives you a
little bit of protection there